and very often it comes from unexpected
areas my other great passion in life
besides art and contemporary art
particular is music rock pop hip hop
world music all types of contemporary
music now one of the greatest
contributions of in the cultural
contemporary art world over the last 25
years has been the whole hip-hop
movement I mean I what I love the music
by great singers like Tupac Shakur Kanye
West or jay-z or fifty cents these are
great artists in a universal sense and
there have been great influences they
had on the Japanese popular artists like
Murakami like mr. the that's his artist
name or Naga these are all artists that
have a close link to the hip-hop culture
and so these fascinating crosscurrents
between Japanese contemporary art and
African American musical culture these
things that have created a culture where
all the young people the way the dress
the whole fashion sense all that has
evolved and has been a major cultural
influence and what we see today and I
think it's to identify these changes
that take place which often come from
the street which comes from the music
which come from fashion which come from
totally new unexpected areas that shape
the art of tomorrow and that's what's
truly is exciting
I think that even areas which seem uh
nart is take a first sight like a lawyer
for a sense or a banker can be so
innovative or so creative that it become
great artists for me one of the greatest
artists in the 21st century and the 20th
century Steve Jobs what is done with
Apple that is true art to get totally
excited by an object that you look at
which is a an object like a portable
phone or or an iPod that gives you such
a kick that is like being excited by a
work of art so yes you can make anything
you do transform it into a major off